It's what they,
that's kind of what they've done.
I mean,
um,
obviously the uh,
like the Louis C K situation,
I know that is so people are so divided on that one.
And my opinion is if,
if he didn't do anything,
um,
make anyone do anything against their will,
he's just a guy that has a strange proclivity,
you know,
he likes jerking off in front of people.
Apparently the cat's out of the bag there,
but like where those girls that upset 20 years ago with a,
that upset 20 years ago that,
that now it's an issue or with a giggling where they let like I need to know how
they were then cause I don't give a fuck what you think now.
Like at the time,
what was it?
Okay.
Was it cool with you?
Oh,
did you sit there and fucking rib elbow to the ribs with your girlfriend and go
look at the sky jerking off in front of us?
Uh,
to me,
I don't care what,
what time has done because it,
the,
the way something looks,
the morality or ethics or respect that is expected in 2018 ain't what it was 20
years ago.
Right.
So you can't be held liable for something you did 20 years ago when it was
normal or a little strange or whatever the fuck it was.
Well,
I think it's always been weird to beat off in front of people.
That's an odd thing to do.
No.
The same thing about it is though he asked if he could write,
and this is something that I've,
I've brought up to be,
oh,
you know,
when people say,
Oh,
you know,
he would lock these women in the room and beat off I to stop.
Okay,
if you're gonna,
if you're gonna like push this,
you're saying that because that fits your narrative.
He's this abusive person who's abusing his power.
Now here's another problem with that.
When this was all going down,
he wasn't very famous.
No,
that's just a two.
So what power was he abusing?
He,
he was a successful comedian.
He was admired by his peers because he was really funny.
He wasn't Louis C k like the superstar filling out Madison Square Garden.
Louis C.
K.
Yeah.
It wasn't the same guy.
You know,
he,
he didn't even have all the HBO specials and all the Netflix specials.
Same Guy.
So he was just another comic.
They'd like to beat off in front of people and he would ask first.
So when you say that he,
you know,
forced these women and wouldn't let them leave,
none of them say that.
In fact,
he asked and when they said no,
he didn't do it,
he didn't say,
oh,
well good.
You don't want me to beat off down and make it feel even better when I beat off
in front of you.
I'll shut the fuck up and sit down.
You know,
he doesn't do it.
No,
no.
He was asking which is,
which is so strange but weird thing.
It's not,
it's,
it's not in the same realm as,
as Harvey Weinstein not even fucking know.
It's not even close.
But people don't want you to rationalize.
No,
don't want you to grade things.
They just want to talk about abuse.
All abuse gets shoveled into this one little pie chart area.
Like this is male abusers.
Yeah.
And then they'll put Matt Lauer right next to bill Cosby,
right next to Louis Ck.
Like,
well,
this seems kind of crazy.
And then when you say it's crazy,
like Matt said,
let's,
I think we should make a distinction.
They like,
oh yeah,
you can't be your,
you'll become a rape apologist if you,
uh,
if you say things like that.
And,
uh,
it,
it's weird.